less than 48 hours ago impeachment
seemed like a remote possibility Speaker
of the House was not for it Joe Biden
the leading presidential candidate had
not come out in favor of it now just a
couple days later it looks almost
certain why not because we've learned
anything new about the president we have
not we've not found a new trove of
compromising documents there's no blurry
iPhone video in which the president
swears fealty to Vladimir Putin that
information is probably not going to
emerge because it doesn't exist and
never has this point years of
Investigations and many millions spent
trying to find it nobody has found any
evidence that the president colluded
with Russia in order to win the 2016
election doesn't matter though yesterday
Robert Muller delivered a statement in
which he said essentially I couldn't
prove the president committed a crime
but I also couldn't prove he didn't
commit a crime on the basis of that
suddenly Democrats appear to be united
tonight we must impeach anybody who
looks at the politics of this it's it's
it's a thorny path but I think history's
gonna look back at this moment and what
we choose to do and see if we did the
right thing and I think the right thing
right now is to hold this president
accountable for his actions we have to
get the show on the road we have to have
these investigations done on TV under
the banner of an impeachment inquiry I
don't think there's any way around that
make everybody vote make everybody in
the house both send it over to the
Senate make them vote put them on the
record and make them live with those
votes for the rest of what it is
impeachment is a process not a thing
they need to move toward it
strategically and they need to make sure
they're bringing the American people
along with them I would suggest that he
told us enough to interpret what he said
as a referral for impeachment
so that was a parade of democratic
politicians mostly presidential can
discuss one fake Republican strategist
so of course they're gonna be for
impeachment the regular press is
supposed to provide some context though
and level-headed analysis of what this
might mean but that's not what we've
gotten over the past two days instead
it's been almost an unending stream of
hyperbole and hysterics here's a small
sample we began with a litany of Lies
from the
student of the United States just one
day after special counsel Robert Muller
again but this time on camera explained
he did not clear the president of a
crime a president who theoretically can
break any law he wants going forward so
long as 34 senators decide to stick with
him
Muller did not say the I word I don't
think anyone was bracing for that today
that's not how Bob mother rolls he
considers this an emergency he considers
this a very serious effort by Russia to
interfere with our election that it
happened that it's going to happen again
a litany of Lies an emergency a
president who can break any law you know
what if you're that excited go ahead and
impeach the president Democrats ran last
year on health care and income
inequality things that voters appeared
to be interested in how excited will
voters be to see the next year and a
half blown on an impeachment trial that
will not succeed waste time and money
and achieve nothing it might be
interesting to find out actually Pelosi
may be extreme but she's not stupid
there's a reason that she's been against
impeachment from day one because she
knows it will hurt her own party but her
party doesn't care so go ahead impeach
him i telled unless they've been another
fact robert muller speech yesterday said
a lot more about him and his
investigation than it did about the
subject of his investigation in his
remarks yesterday Muller said that it
was important that quote the offices
written work speak for itself
the written work of course is his report
we've had that for a month and obviously
didn't justify impeachment so Muller
decided to speak up and tip the scales
in a different direction that was the
point of yesterday's comments he said
that he was unable to exonerate the
president of criminal activity so it's
up to Congress to decide what to do of
course in a fair society in all fair
societies prosecutors never exonerate
people prosecutors either charged people
with crimes or they leave them alone
prosecutors are not supposed to release
embarrassing material about private
citizens unless it directly relates to a
criminal offense like some of the other
people in Washington though Muller and
his team forgot that basic principle and
so thanks to their work our country will
be suffering through another year of
pointless political theater will
the real problems fester and get worse
opioid student loans the border the rise
of China
take your pick there are so many none of
those will get fixed instead we're gonna
have a pointless impeachment show trial
which we're gonna do to flee cover
it'll be depressing but we'll have no
choice